the Prime Minister Boris Johnson has
just released a video message giving an
update on his recovery from covert 19 he
says he's feeling better but still has
some minor symptoms
he's also pleaded with the public to
stick to the lockdown rules this weekend
hi folks quick update for me on campaign
against coronavirus first of all in my
own case although I'm feeling better and
I've done my my seven days of isolation
alas I still have one of the symptoms of
- symptom of I have a temperature and so
in accordance with government advice I
must continue myself isolation until
that symptom itself goes but we're
working clearly the whole time on our
program to defeat the virus you have
seen the big announcement yesterday
about a hundred thousand tests per day
by the end of the month and I just want
to say one crucial thing one quick thing
to everybody thinking about this weekend
and what may be some funny weather
because I reckon a lot of people will be
starting to think that this is all going
on for quite a long time and they'd
rather be getting out there and
particularly they put you've got kids in
there the household everybody may be
getting a bit stir-crazy and there may
be just a temptation to get out there
hang out and and start to to break the
regulations and I just urge you not to
do that please please stick with the
guidance now this country has made a
huge effort a huge sacrifice done
absolutely brilliantly well in delaying
the spread of the virus let's stick with
it now remember that incredible clapping
again last night for our fantastic NHS
were doing it to protect them and to
save lives let's focus on doing
everything we can stay at home folks
protect our NHS save lives speak soon